[Music]
foreign
and thank you for joining us for the
final episode of The Season's data for
the people presented by Rocky to use
science Outreach my name is Devin
Collins and I'm program manager for
outreach and engagement at Rock EDU data
for the people is an interactive web
series that invites all people to engage
with relevant scientific research topics
presented by scientists from our
communities the theme for this season of
data for the people has been people and
medicine and during the season we've
explored the science of how we study
ourselves we've explored our
complexities organisms how our
identities and characteristics can
create challenges and opportunities for
understanding humans and human health
and we've also looked at things like how
historical biases and power structures
have influenced scientific knowledge and
continue to influence scientific
scientific knowledge and biomedical
studies we've also thought about how
we've been able to get better and how we
can continue to get better at studying
ourselves by creating better more
comprehensive and more just studies
um so I am very excited today
uh because we have many of the speakers
from uh this season here to answer more
of your questions and lend us more of
their thoughts about
um about this season's theme uh so the
rocky team and I have come up with a
couple of like questions that we can
kind of like Spike into you all
um but really we just want to open this
up for folks in the audience to uh and
to ask more questions about people and
Medicine
um I'll remind everyone that we are not
uh giving any sort of medical advice we
are not medical doctors we are all phds
or students or uh and post-docs and so
uh we are not qualified or neither would
it be appropriate for us to give you
medical advice but
um we can think a lot about how uh
scientists like us uh can study people
um so please try to keep your questions
tailored um to that theme
um yeah so uh why don't I give everyone
just a quick chance to introduce
themselves again just like you know tell
us who you are uh what you like to study
and
um what organization you're working with
um and I'm gonna start uh to my left the
first person uh on my screen is Genie
hi I think um my dogs might start
barking so I apologize
um but I'm Jeannie garberino I work on
the rocky to you team
um and I am just really excited to be
here for another season of d4p so this
is my third season I'm working on this
project and really glad that you all can
tune in
all right next on my screen is Victor
hi everyone I'm Victor I'm a PhD student
at one Cornell medicine
and
um I really love to study the like
really integral
um mechanisms and like inner workings of
molecules and just really small things
that you know relate to our biology
thanks uh lee you're next
hi Lee box I'm a scientist at the
tri-institutional Therapeutics Discovery
Institute
um we're a drug accelerator that works
with wild Cornell Rockefeller University
and Memorial Sloan Kettering professors
in pre-clinical drug development as you
might guess I'm interested in
translational research and taking steps
that bring us closer to affecting
patients lives I'm also passionate about
mentoring people in their scientific
career paths and introducing people to
careers outside of Academia
glad to be here
thanks Lee uh Luth you're next
hi I'm Luke jubierre and I am a postdoc
at msk in the Alex Kansas lab and
basically my work consists of studying
brain development and DNA damage
produced by a protein called pbd5 and
yeah
thanks
um Angela
hi I'm Angela I'm also a PhD student at
Wild Cornell medicine and I'm really
interested in studying hosts microbe
interactions I right now I'm studying
tuberculosis
thank you uh Jude
uh hey everyone I'm a third third year
grad student at Wild Cornell and I'm
studying the interplay between
transcription factors in the
administration of prostate cancer
thanks dude and then last but not least
Nora
oh no it looks like more might be frozen
yeah okay we'll give Dory a chance to
introduce herself in just a bit
um once she figures out her her
connection
um but in the meantime I'm gonna jump
right into my first question for all of
you um and as someone who got the who
had the like the honor of of sitting and
talking to you at um at many different
stages of like preparing for your talks
and like getting to go to all of your
talks
um my big question for you is um and you
can yell at me if it's too big but you
all covered a few really large and sort
of overarching issues that really touch
on almost every aspect of of scientific
research that in general but also like
especially scientific research that
bears on humans and and human health so
I'm wondering like for you personally in
your field what are some of the big
questions or priorities that that Loom
large for you
um that you'd like to see us get better
at or see see more data around or or
whatever pops into your mind
and I think anyone can can take them
don't everyone catch up at the same time
I guess I can start it is a really big
question and um like I said I study like
the really integral mechanisms of
molecules but um particularly like I
said I study molecules that are super
relevant to human biology and you know
like I'm sure many of us went over in
our talks those are mostly proteins
so of course proteins are you know
running kind of a lot of the
biochemistry and a lot of the mechanisms
in our bodies
and I think what I'm kind of looking
forward to in my field really is
improving
the techniques that we actually use to
study the really core you know integral
chemistry and physics of like what's
going on with the different molecules uh
you know that underpin a lot of our
biology
I think there are a lot of like in my
field in particular that there are a lot
of like you know theories and
um kind of like big ideas about how a
lot of things work but um currently it's
just really difficult to test a lot of
them because
the technology and the um I guess like
ability to assay those things just
doesn't really exist or isn't at the
frontier of our like Theory quite yet so
I think what I'm really looking forward
to is improving our Improvement in in
those Technologies
our ability to actually like assay a
certain
you know hypotheses and theories
yeah
yeah I think that's a that's such a big
job right I I know for in my own
research uh and I studied addiction as a
grad student and a postdoc and it can be
you know so it's a very fundam not
fundamentally but it is a very human
issue that I would study and we used a
lot of mouse and cellular assays but we
can't ask mice how they feel and we
can't ask cells how they feel especially
we can only kind of like you know kind
of model
kind of right model the things that that
are going on in humans and make a lot of
assumptions about what correlates to
what but actually being able to assay
the thing that we care about and and get
at it without the complications of of
you know the way that culture or you
know other aspects can can uh influence
what we think about you know what we
think about people's answers or what
their answers will be much less what we
think about the disease that we study
it's it's really hard so really getting
at the core of what you're
and being able to assay exactly the
thing that you need is is a really tough
tough order so by wishing you luck I
hope it works out
uh does anybody else want to jump in I
can also maybe we can narrow the
question a little bit to what is what is
the question that you're most interested
in that your work that you think your
work addresses
um I would just like to expand on what
um you guys are done and um Victor were
talking about using mice models
um because and this is just more broadly
in Immunology we use a lot of mice
models
um but it might have different immunity
compared to humans
um for one thing they have short life
spans and they you have many more
litters versus Humans only have maybe a
few children at a time and we have much
longer life spans so how our immune
system reacts at different pathogens are
going to be different than what mice are
going to do and so it has been difficult
and I think with covid
um there was this uh kind of people saw
that there was this problem that we know
a lot about how mice work but we don't
know that much about how human immune
system works
um and there is
some technologies coming out where we
use human organoids to try to more mimic
the human Immunology but it's still not
a perfect system and it's still not in
Vivo and of course we can't really do in
Vivo a lot of envivable work
um because it would be an ethical for
the reasons that we've discussed
previously in the
um in the session
um but yes I think more technology for
organoids and those type of systems
might help
yeah I I think that's a really great
point I I wonder oh yeah Lee go ahead I
just wanted to add to that from the
perspective of drug development I know
that the fact that mice don't
recapitulate human biology is a huge
issue because most preclinical work
um going into very early drug
development is done in mice and mice has
been cured of cancer many many many
times but uh we don't at this time have
very many ways to cure various human
cancers so you know that's just a
testament to the fact that mice are a
challenge there's lots of pre-clinical
work done in other species dogs primates
you know other large animals
um I think specifically for that reason
but you know because of ethical reasons
obviously you can't go into a human
until you know you have something safe
so there is also I think a push for
these more translational models organoid
models co-culture models these like
organs on a chip there's a lot of really
interesting like 3D printing and kind of
3D structured
um you you know model systems that
people are trying to develop but you
know as as far as I know a lot of that
hasn't really been pushed through any
any pre-clinical development to the
point that it was able to show
translation in the clinic because most
of these Technologies are new but it's
definitely an issue in translational
science as well
um I I think an issue that
um I all of these are really excellent
um points of like where we should be
trying to go you know as an Enterprise
um but when I there's something that I
think we haven't really discussed in
this series but I think it's worth
mentioning here in that if we consider
scientific research to be sort of this
interconnected
um you know body of knowledge and it's
and it really is around scientific at
the point of scientific research is to
both generate and organize that
knowledge into some narrative that's
testable
um and uh you know has logical
conclusions and things like that but
there's so much science going on and not
all of it is as interconnected as it
could be and so I think there is a
really big need for better information
architecture when it comes to the output
of scientific research and
um and that could be considered through
the lens of like publication so we've
been talking about peer-reviewed
publication
um and there's other ways that people
are starting to think about
dissemination of scientific research uh
and
where can we find ways to accelerate
that and make sure that um researchers
can connect with each other to sort of
start thinking about what those big
picture pieces are so I do think that we
have there's this other layer outside of
research proper that um really needs to
be solved as we continue to generate
such huge data sets also I mean they're
just ginormous right so
um
those are just some of the thoughts that
I had as a as a non-active researcher
uh related to that Genie actually a lot
of um you know we have a lot of
companies who come to us with various
computational you know things they're
working on one of the things I see a lot
is companies who are trying to
synthesize data from many different
sources for the use of companies working
in pre-clinical drug development to
learn as much as they can about a Target
I mean if we have a new Target we go to
a number of different databases that
have you know Big Data whether those are
like the open targets platform which is
great omim for phenotypic data in humans
Jacks for phenotypic data and mice
um you know protein Atlas cell Atlas the
broad has like the um a bunch of
different resources like there there's
companies who are trying to work to
bring all of this together so that you
can look for a Target and they can give
you all the papers where that particular
protein or Gene was mentioned all the
patents where it was mentioned you know
all of the websites that mention it all
the assays that involve it
um I think I think that's a really kind
of a good step in that direction but
what's unfortunate is that a lot of
Pharma companies who have these types of
things they're like proprietary so only
they have access to it so I think you
know a push for an open source uh
resource like what's provided by cell
Atlas protein Atlas the broad
um you know open source software
packages or you know computer programs
that allow you to kind of synthesize all
that data in one place when you're
interested in one particular Target or
pathway it's a really important thing
that needs to be pushed
yeah I think pushes for more open data
and more or especially more open source
um tools that we can use to compile all
of the data that's out there and bring
it together in a way that that makes
sense is is so useful and I know in my
own practice I was able to make use of
things like that like that like some of
the uh openly available things that like
Jackson and
um some of the things that are on like
Library you know National Library of
Medicine sites and and all of that I'm
wondering how have you all been able to
use those sorts of tools in your own
research and maybe if you have us you
know a favorite that that uh she can let
us know
well for me as a neuroscientist I I have
one of my favorites is the brain Alice
from the Allen brain Atlas and thanks to
that there is like a huge resource on
like how on development of the brain and
the
the full developed brain and just not
like an atlas for the for the mouse
brain um with all the parts that you can
always use as a reference which is very
important because it's very complicated
um but also they are like having a huge
effort also developing now the new
single cell Technologies and generating
Maps like reference maps and that I
think is is very important for for us
researchers to have that and and be able
to use those tools to then study disease
the brains and and have these
um reference map or
for the study for the brain
one um tool that I've used is kaijin's
ingenuity pathway analysis and so this
is um
it's a company but uh they you can put
your RNA sequencing data into this
database and so when you get RNA
sequencing you have like what 20 000
Jews a few more
um about and so if you were to
individually look at these genes it'd be
really difficult to
um analyze each set each gene
um so what you can do is look at this
Gene um set enrichment so you have like
different Pathways and then they can
tell you what those pathways are so
you're you're looking at within a
pathway maybe and also because RNA is
very transient so a gene might be
upregulated at one time and then
non-regulated if you don't have the
right time point so if you're looking at
multiple genes within a pathway and like
seven out of ten of them are graduated
that means that probably the best
pathway is upregulated or X being
expressed and so it's really useful to
um
get back that data what what pathways
are are being expressed
yeah I I really love that idea of being
able to see like a long different points
and maybe some sort of uh I'm trying to
think of a good way to explain but like
like seeing like along the course of a
biological process like what sorts of
endpoints you might see because
sometimes we only get to see a snapshot
of what the biology really looks like at
one given time or at one set of
conditions and being able to see like oh
this Gene is upregulated here or down
regulated here is really cool because we
get more of that global view and not
just in one particular way and I that
that's so important and I don't know if
a lot of scientists like always think
about it that way I I know for me like I
I would get really fixated on one
particular experiment and the outcomes
there but not think about everything and
you know studying the brain like I did
like you really have to think about a
lot of different things at one time not
that the brain isn't is special but
um I mean it is special I think it's
special uh but you know in other organ
systems it works it works really
similarly everything is so complex
yeah so I think those are like really
great tools are there any other tools
that you're you're sort of interested in
I'm thinking about you know
think like big initiatives like the
Human Genome Project or like the brain
initiative you know are there other big
like maybe government-funded or
institution funded or International
collaborations that you have benefited
from or or that you would like to see or
you know around a specific kind of set
of tools or or delineating a certain set
of biological processes
I think probably the most
the two most invaluable for me is kind
of someone that works in like molecular
and like structural biology
are first be like a huge like NIH
database of like genes you know like
um RNA and protein
because there they kind of outline
um you know pretty much all genes that
uh you know that we know of and they
also um catalog like various like human
genomes that have been mapped
um and you know they on those genomes
they map out like all the like
translated proteins
um and also the papers that are like
associated with you know all those genes
and you know translated proteins so it's
like super invaluable just to like be
able to you know look up any Gene that
you want and you know get all the
information on it really quickly
um and then the other one is the protein
Data Bank which is especially you know
really useful for structural biology
because they're
um you kind of get a catalog of all of
the various protein structures that have
been um results experimentally
um and I think also now that like Alpha
gold is a big thing they also catalog
protein structures that have been uh
predicted as well so
both of those are
super super invaluable for molecular and
structural biology in particular
yeah I think tools like oh loose
sorry now that you touch Victor the
alcohol thing I think it's very powerful
because I was just like commenting that
with my co-workers that they are also
developing this new
algorithm where they
um
um simulate also not only the protein
folding but the protein folding together
with DNA or other structures so this is
very powerful and I mean it's never a
definitive
um structure but it can give you an idea
of like when you don't have a
crystallized structure for the molecule
you're working with on how it's
interacting just not by yourself but
with other partners other proteins
complex and and I think it will be very
powerful for the future of predicting
this kind of things when you don't have
the actual crystal structure that takes
years to get right so Victoria know much
more about this than me but the lab that
the part of the lab that is interested
on that they were like very excited yeah
these days they actually can also
simulate things like um you know
different like drugs binding to the
proteins and stuff and they can you know
predict like what the structure is going
to look like with the drug bound or like
various other molecules so yeah there's
a lot of stress ads in the field of like
you know computational prediction of
molecular interactions and stuff so it's
really exciting
those resources are actually really
heavily used in the drug development
industry as well there's a lot of people
putting efforts into like AI driven and
other computational methods for driving
drug Discovery so if you have a really
high resolution structure of a compound
that can be used to run virtual screens
and other ways of looking for potential
binders you can't yet look at it and say
this is the compound that'll fit in
there like we're not there yet but I
hope someday
I I
oh go ahead yeah I I just I just a
comment I just think that these are all
so it's really amazing like thinking
back to the comment that you made Lee
about the necessity for a lot of these
open source
um projects and and databases being
associated with one another and working
in tandem I really love that we can you
know we're at a point where
computationally we can take a lot of
this data make it into meaningful
representations of the biology and then
see how all those different you know
once disparate databases and structures
really work together to get a better
model of what actually is going on and
not just having to imagine or you know
having to think about like well maybe if
I look at this time or maybe if I catch
this event here like you get a better
idea of when and where to look in cells
or when and where to look in whole
animals or whole people and that's a
really amazing tool that opens up a lot
of biology in a lot of different kinds
of ways of thinking about our
experiments for us
so uh there is a question
um from the audience and this is really
interesting because they're bringing up
holding at home
um which we know is taking place at Wild
Cornell so on the topic of Open Source
tooling and data collection is anyone
here familiar with holding at home we
are familiar with it or at least some of
us are
um and similar projects how helpful have
they been in progressing research
this is so crazy because I use holding a
home actually for my research so it's
kind of cool to see that you know people
actually know what it is I thought like
nobody knew only a comments but
um it's like absolutely integral to my
research because I actually use it um
basically to study or rather to predict
computationally how like various
molecules are like interacting with
others
um and it's been like like I said
invaluable to me because it basically
enables you to do
um various computations that would be
like impossible to do with just like
single computers or just like even like
a computational cluster
um and for anyone that doesn't know what
holding a home is it's basically like uh
um distributed computing Network which
basically lets you like borrow the
computing power of like volunteered
computers to make like one giant
supercomputer
um and I think at some point last year
two years ago or something it was
actually the like most powerful
supercomputer in the world or something
so
um cool to see it mentioned here
yeah we had um one of the developers of
folding at home
um join us for us uh Summit that Rocky
do you hosted a few uh weeks ago and it
was really cool to hear the stat that
you accident they accidentally built the
large the world's largest supercomputer
for like several moments in time or
something like that
yeah that was a really cool that's a
really cool piece of trivia that we get
to learn
so I kind of want to change
um change gears just just for a moment
um maybe for longer than a moment
um but I'm I'm thinking more about you
know again like the the theme has been
people and medicine and we've talked a
lot you know we've just gotten done
talking about a lot of the tools that we
use or the tools we'd like to see but I
kind of want to think about about the
people and I know you know for example
we we heard from uh Nora and Lee
about how we can make more just studies
that really honor the communities that
we are
um that we are working with and
understanding you know how to do things
like build trust and I wonder
um for all of you but maybe specifically
starting with with with Leonora
um what are your thoughts on how we can
be better at you know ethically
constructing
um studies that involve human uh human
participants
yeah sure I can speak to that um I'm
Nora by the way I didn't get to
introduce myself earlier because I was
having some technical difficulties but I
work at the tri-institutional
Therapeutics Discovery Institute along
the fleet
um so I guess I'll kind of summarize our
talk because we we talked a lot about
this specifically focusing on indigenous
communities and um people doing doing
research with indigenous communities
particularly genomics research
um and
sort of a lot of what we talked about
was was how this could be done ethically
and basically it kind of boiled down to
that researchers and the communities to
really work together in partnership in
order to to do these studies
um and should really create sort of
um close Partnerships and trust and
build trust that um the data is going to
be used ethically and with the best
interest of the communities in mind and
so
um that sort of
um yeah referred to as like Community
engagement
um and I think that that's a really
important aspect of of doing research on
humans is not just treating them as
subjects but as treating them as like
you're giving your DNA or whatever
you're giving to this project and
um
that deserves credit and
um respect and should should be treated
as such and should in the end help the
communities that are that are being
researched and not
um do do harm to them so yeah that was
sort of the thesis of our talk
um
yeah I think that's such a that's such a
good point I as I was asking you the
question I felt myself having to stop
and say I I've gotten so used just
because I've heard this so much human
subjects human subjects human subjects
but really it's participants or maybe
that's not even the best word that's the
word I like to use right now but you're
taking that I think even a step forward
and especially you know some of the
themes that you covered and and the
actual initiatives you covered in your
talk was really human Partners like
research Partners it's not just that
people are participating in research
studies or should participate in
research studies they are making it
possible to to do the work in the first
place and so it really is a partnership
and you know those Partners might be
contributing different things like some
of them maybe contributing like you know
offering their own like biological
material but that doesn't make them any
less of a partner in the research and
and I think we have to honor that and
think about that from the bottom up not
just you know bringing that in after we
decided oh we need this from from X
group or ex-people like really thinking
about you know just the idea that
it is through the generosity of folks
who uh interact with us that we're able
to get done the studies that we we want
to
maybe I'll just add on to that as well
like another another theme was sort of
thinking about the impact that that
research has and particularly for groups
that have been historically taken
advantage of for for Science and other
things like you know there's there
should be particular care take in there
to gain the trust and respect of those
of those groups and make sure that that
the outcomes of those research are like
culturally sensitive and actually
helping the communities in the end
I wonder if anybody has thoughts on
where like we we know that scientists
and I think we've talked a little bit
about that in many of the talks like
scientists have specific sorts of
responsibilities to
um the people who participate in their
studies or just to you know just
ethically there are certain ethical
obligations that we have in general no
matter what kinds of science we're doing
but I wonder where else you know the
responsibility might lie is it with do
you see like a role for policy or
governments and kind of directing what
scientists can and can't do like
obviously they're there already are many
policies and sorts of rules in place and
funding agencies might have their own
rules but I wonder like what are what
are some of the big things that you you
know or where where might we like look
for guidance or or you know power to be
able to Institute rules that we need to
keep ourselves honest or keep ourselves
ethical
so I think I'm just talking about what
rules are already in place or what
regulations or institutions are already
in place
um we have something called the IRB I
think it stands for institutional review
board so this is a council of people
within an institution
that in order to do any type of human
subject to research you have to get
approval from them and the board
consists has to consist of at least one
scientist and one layered person so
someone who's not a scientist to
represent the general public and they
have to weigh the risks and benefits of
the study and to make sure that the
benefits of the study outweigh any risk
and to make sure that there is no undue
harm
um onto the participants
um
and yes and you have to go through this
process anytime you want to do human
research and with that said like there
are criterias for what is considered to
be human research so if you are doing
something completely anonymously you
don't know where the like let's say you
receive samples from somebody and you
have no idea where those samples came
from and who are the people are that
would be considered not human research
because you don't personally know who
those people are but you still have to
get IRB approval to make sure that that
is considered not human research
um so there are that is something that's
already in place
it might be worth mentioning that while
um
um we do have these this institutional
Review Board in place which is a an
essential component for people to be
able to provide their informed consent
to be
um
uh in in participating in research I
think there's also issues with who
actually is being consented and who is
being recruited like we're not
recruiting a representative sampling of
our of our population in the United
States for clinical studies right and
because
um because there isn't representation in
clinical studies uh
there isn't necessarily representation
in how we develop medicines and
treatments and drugs right and that
might be actually a problem so I think
um
a question that I've always had was
something around like how can we improve
the relationship that science has with
communities and I know we sort of talked
about it a little bit
um through the paper
um discussed by uh Leonora
um but there's got to be better ways to
sort of think about Community engagement
participatory science
um like for example I know there has
been a lot of progress through
communication of science through barber
shops uh as one example and I know
there's a lot of people working to do
vaccine communication through faith
um uh Faith organizations right so what
what is required for science to Showcase
that it is actually
trustworthy or at least a lot more
trustworthy than it used to be
um I could add to that I think one
effort to
wait hold up Amaya Cohen
no you're good you're good all right
yeah so I think one effort to me that
end is um so before in clinics like
people um doctors or clinicians used to
like um
um stratify patients based off like
um dear like definition of like their
ancestry rights but nowadays like people
are like um using genetics I would say
to Define people's ancestries and um
that better serves um patient
stratification and development of drugs
because like now like
um
the studies like studies that we do here
in the lab would better like represent
um what's happening in a specific
patient rather than like using like a
small small subset which doesn't
represent like all patients
yeah I think it's it's interesting to be
able to get like uh and especially in
places like I mean I I live and know you
know the US the best because that's
where that's where I'm from but thinking
about places where there are really big
big admixed populations of many
different people who may or may not
share ancestry from many different
places it's really I think one really
great thing that we can do better now
and that we can continue to do better is
to recruit a lot of folks irrespective
of our own assumptions about where they
come from or what their genetics or what
their ancestry might be we can actually
just look and find out like okay of the
people who have volunteered to take part
in the study
what are their biological
characteristics or what are their
genetic characteristics and you know
they may report one thing that more
aligns closely with their own culture or
with their family history but you know
if we see something else genetically
that that just it doesn't contradict
what they've said it just adds to the
richness of of the information that we
have and we have better tools to be able
to think about it more in more complex
ways at all
um yeah
I think um there's also the other side
of the equation which is sometimes
people are participating in the settings
because they want to receive some
monetary compensation and so there may
be certain populations that are
more vulnerable to be doing riskier
research because they're in a
impoverished situation and so that's
also something important to think about
and it's it is I have to say it is
really difficult to get
um a diverse
to recruit a diverse population in my
own research
um and yeah I'm trying to think as well
how to better get more diversity
but also without
um without
um
not coursing but like without uh
targeting people who just want it for
the money
yeah that's such a good point I and it's
something I don't always think about
excuse me myself but really when we were
thinking about Partnerships like one of
the things that people should be
compensated in some way or they should
be you know they're things that we need
to do to take care of folks so I know
for my own research we would do you know
some inpatient or outpatient care for
people who are people with addictive
diseases while they were in our studies
and one of the benefits for them is that
they got to you know if they didn't have
insurance or if they were you know for
some other reason we're not able to
access medical care they could at least
get that care at the time that they were
you know in the hospital doing our um
you know working with us on our on our
studies but then that could also you
know things like that can also bias the
populations that you get because maybe
folks who have other routes of care for
the same disease may not participate in
your study because they don't need that
care or they don't need the money that
people can offer or things like that and
it's really interesting I know at least
in my field there are folks who you know
who are studying that and understanding
like why trying to understand why folks
are making the decisions they do not
only about
um you know the care and management of
their addictive disease but also you
know how they participate in studies
it's it's interesting to think about
that but I I love that there are
scientists who are who are looking at
those those questions
so I think I would love to hear speci
this this question has sort of been
rattling around in my head for a couple
of a couple of weeks ever since uh your
talk with
um you you talked a little bit about
psychedelics
um
I I you talked a little bit about
psychedelics and
um one thing that I know I encountered
in my own research is that you couldn't
it's it's tough for some scientists to
study
um certain drugs or use certain kinds of
tools because of social stigma or even
the laws that are on on the books I
wonder if you have any thoughts about
you know what sorts of policy changes or
what sorts of you know things we can do
to fight stigma against
you know about drug use or other other
diseases you know to be able to study
them better
um if there's anything that you you have
in mind
um it is very complicated because
everything is tied up it's not not like
science is separate from from the
population issues and I was gonna make a
comment before but I guess my time
passed and on the topic before like
sometimes the government like as I said
in my in my talk can forbid
to study 13 things right so you still
need these regulations in place you need
the regulation so you know psychedelics
cannot be misused by by people but can
be used as a way to just like treat
patients and just not psychedelic
opioids or any other type of drug that
right now it is useful in some ways for
humans but misuse can lead to to disease
and health problems so
it is very complicated for this reason
that um
if you really release the like lacks the
loss and then
people can use it
broadly you end up with a problem but if
you restrict it restrict it so much and
it stigmatize it so much that you decide
this is not helpful at all then you end
up stopping the the research progress so
there is
these model bottle right between science
and community and and I guess you made a
point before that for us is to educate
people to educate for both the risks and
the benefits and
and I know there was I'm not from from
the US but I have such a different
relationship with how like view of drugs
because I came from Spain and I knew I
know like when I came here but there's a
lot of people that tells me there was
this huge campaign against drugs that
demonized it and and demonized their use
versus back in Spain I never had this
huge focus on on that like I had some
education on drugs but I remember people
coming and telling me the the risk of of
taking the drugs and but the benefits of
how to use them in clinic and I never I
guess like I never fear them or
it was just like I respect right like in
in here when you over stigmatize
something you can get the the opposite
effect so you end up like having people
that ends up very you know like you you
want to break the rules and then you end
up abusing the drugs versus like if you
understand
look there is a risk in everything that
I that I do and
I don't want to get into this field of
like I don't know taking psychedelics
because then I know what it can do to my
brain so you understand and then I don't
know it just for me it is this this
balance in between giving the
information and then letting trust in
the people is going to make the the
right choices and you're you're a drug
researcher and I believe like in the in
the touch of drug addiction especially
people usually don't get addicted to
drugs just because like usually they get
addicted to drugs because they are using
it as a scape so people that get
they don't usually have like situations
that are like ideal in in their in their
environment like
and obviously there is it's very complex
um problem but anyway I think
putting these models
um is good and bad in in science and as
a scientist we have to educate the
people so and believe that um they make
the right choice and also the government
to do the part where like they take care
of their people and then you end up with
less people in bad situations that they
end up you know have you seen this type
of substances in that in that case and
then obviously there is a lot of other
like stem cells and and other people
that don't believe you know there are a
lot of debates and moral debates that
you can get into the weeds into those
but yeah I think the the solution is
always is education and trusting that
people with the right
um knowledge is gonna make the right
choices in the right space like
obviously I'm not saying but
yeah
yeah I I love that you bring up
education and like giving people just
like access to information I guess you
know that's that's what d4p is all about
is making sure that everyone is able to
access the information that we're we can
I think a scientist can kind of take for
granted that access
um I have I have one final question for
everyone uh well hopefully it'll be a
little bit more fun
um not that these have not been fun but
I I want to have like a like definitely
fun question for you
um and that question is
we have like you know we we've all been
talking about humans and health uh for
this season and I would love to hear
from um from the from all of you why
what excites you or what do you love
about studying uh humans and and human
diseases
yeah
I can break the ice too if you want the
thing I really liked uh when I when I
was at the bench the thing that I really
liked was that I got to all the labs I
ever worked in
um had to do with human disease and
health
um and were translational so the things
that we studied in the lab had Direct
bearing on you know actual illnesses
that that people have and experience and
it was really cool because I got to
meets a lot of the folks who took part
in our research and especially when I've
studied things like rare diseases like
rare neurological diseases we got to
know the families
um that that like were carriers of the
disease mutations that we looked at
um and it was just really cool to be
able to again like have that partnership
with them and we we shared data with
them and they helped us to get funding
and they were able to like come and tell
us very personally about the symptoms of
their illnesses and really describe in
detail and we have we were able to have
like a personal relationship and so
being able to see directly the like
results not even if we like couldn't
find the quote-unquote Cure uh you know
we got closer with like things like
treatments but
um it was just cool to see how happy
they were to work with us and and how
much they came to trust us over the
years and that was really special to me
so getting to see the like impact the
human impact was was really cool
I guess for me the coolest thing is
um just being able to bring you know
what I know from the science that I was
training which I was never trained
formally in like biology or chemistry I
was trained formally in physics actually
um so for me the coolest thing I think
is just bringing you know Concepts from
physics which are obviously important to
you know biology and human health as
like a larger topic just bringing those
Concepts and you know bridging meant
multiple like interdisciplinary like
sciences and disciplines and and doing
all of that to kind of in some way uh
you know from my basic science research
to improve um you know outcomes of
Health I think that's just the most
exciting thing for me
I think for me the most exciting thing
is
being able to better understand
ourselves
um as humans and specifically in like
methodology and Immunology it's
something that we can't normally see on
a daily basis something we have to see
under the micro system and like seeing
images of infected cells or seeing how
our cells react is really cool and then
also getting results and figuring out
better how what what more about
ourselves that we don't normally see on
that by the naked eye
okay I'm gonna go jump in for my answer
to this
um I think for me I'm gonna be a little
bit like really textbook nerdy and say
that um so I did a lot of research on
cholesterol intracellular lipids
phospholipids
um uh like triglycerides things that
make your membranes and things like that
so I feel really jazzed about
intermolecular forces like I love
thinking about how little tiny
um so this is going really granular I
love thinking how little tiny changes in
like a DNA sequence that leads to a
little tiny change in the protein
sequence how that completely changes how
a molecule can interact with its
surroundings and with other molecules so
I love that kind of stuff it's like a
really cool puzzle
um you don't even have to study whole
body systems you could just study a cell
uh to figure that stuff out you don't
even have to study a wholesale you could
just study like and you know and what's
inside your nucleus or something it's
like there's so
that you can go so far through I know
intermolecular forces feel like a little
boring in your textbook but they were
just literally the coolest thing in real
life
I can answer
um I think so I I work now on drug
development making drugs and finding
drugs to cure diseases and I really like
working on something that
can maybe really impact someone's life
and and be beneficial to to people
um and so that's very motivating and
that's the reason why I like working
on drugs too
I guess for me the most motivating thing
is to understand how our brain is formed
and how it actually works because it's
one of the areas that is less understood
in biology because of the fact that we
cannot take samples of the brain because
we it's not like you can maybe take a
sample of the liver and you still
survive but you cannot take a pace of
your brain and in the world
so I think for me that answering this
question is the most exciting thing and
how yeah I work more in the development
part
but answering and I work with a cellular
diversity so understanding how the brain
is composed by different cells that are
different
and diverse to one another and they
communicate within each other is yeah
it's the coolest thing for me
oh yeah um I want to add to that too so
um I think what's exciting in my
research is
um
so I like to think of cancer as like
that um toxic Exile like never goes away
um it kind of finds like ways to come
back and like just make your life like
you know help
um and what I do in my lab is like to
like identify like the key like
transcription transcriptional machinery
and epigenetic Machinery which like
transforms like normal prostate cancer
to um I mean a normal prostate two
prostate cancer and that in itself is
like super exciting because if we can
like actually like figure out like the
key mechanisms which are being like
disrupted
um we can sort of avoid like the late
stage like really bad like forms of
cancer
okay
yeah so getting better at detecting
everything before before it goes wrong
yeah those are all really wonderful
answers thank you